[Música]
17 muertos dejan tres masacres en las
últimas 24 horas en diferentes regiones
de colombia en las que grupos criminales
se disputan el control enlazamos con el
director ejecutivo del centro de
estudios de seguridad y paz
y la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó un paquete de ayuda al servicio
postal y bloqueó los cambios que
generaban preocupación de cara a las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre
en menos de 24 horas conoceremos al
equipo ganador de la liga de campeones o
el psg francés se lleva la copa europea
por primera vez entre historia o el
alemán bayern munich y lo hará por sexta
vez tenemos reporte desde la ciudad de
lisboa
buenas noches bienvenidos a las noticias
aquí en france 24 mi nombre es talan
austria empezamos en sudamérica y es que
tres masacres en 24 horas a la hermana
los colombianos los hechos se
registraron en los departamentos de
nariño cauca y arauca que coinciden en
que tienen áreas con expansión del
cultivo de coca en dos semanas ya son
seis matanzas en el país el gobierno
anunció la creación de un grupo para
investigar estos homicidios mientras
aumenta el rechazo de los ciudadanos es
por ello que enlazamos con el director
ejecutivo del centro de estudios en
seguridad y paz en colombia' gracias por
esta comunicación en bogotá a néstor
rosa ni a estas tres masacres se suman a
otras 33 que hubo en todo el año según
la onu que está pasando en colombia
buenas noches para ti y para todos los
televidentes tres cosas fundamentales
primero el conflicto armado colombiano
se descentralizó quiere decir que ya no
tenemos grandes organizaciones y
estructuras como fueron las farc los
paramilitares u otras organizaciones si
no tenemos son pequeñas células pequeños
grupos que se están disputando el
negocio del narcotráfico en todo el país
que sean pequeñas estructuras hace que
sea mucho más difícil porque ya no hay
un mando único indefinido y lo segundo
colombiano sigue siendo el primer
productor de cocaína a nivel mundial y
el 70% de esa cocaína sale por la costa
pacífica de nariño y cauca donde hemos
visto estas masacres o por araba calor
de santander
buscando la salida hacia venezuela por
donde vivimos la masacre de web
entonces dónde están las fronteras y los
corredores de la salida de cocaína
estamos viendo las masas
bien director qué opinión le merece el
actuar del gobierno de iván duque que
debe priorizar su administración para
responder ante la violencia y los puntos
que no se están identificando
tres cosas fundamentales primero ha sido
un error histórico del gobierno de ban
duque porque no implementó dos los
acuerdos de paz de la habana
implementar algo que se llama hagan
planes de desarrollo de desarrollo con
enfoque territorial no lo hizo y eso es
lo que dejó fue un espacio de vacío que
preocupaba por todos estos actores
armados ilegales primero lo segundo que
tienen que hacer en este momento un plan
de choque militar y policial para
recuperar el control en esos territorios
y tercero lo más importante es que el
estado llegue por fin a estos
territorios olvidados en estos
territorios donde están las masacres no
hay una presencia del estado en términos
de salud economías legales educación
infraestructura y sobre todo el tema de
economías legales mientras no haya un
modelo económico que se le compita al
tema narcotráfico pues necesariamente
estos grupos armados van a seguir en
esos territorios y matando a la gente
porque ellos quieren tener el control
territorial y el control de la salida de
los corredores
pues muchas gracias por esta
comunicación y sus palabras nuestro
rosanía el es director ejecutivo del
centro de estudios en seguridad y paz en
colombia' del sur nos vamos al norte del
continente americano y es que en eeuu la
cámara de representantes aprobó entregar
25 mil millones de dólares al servicio
postal y bloquear así los cambios que
generaban preocupación de cara a las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre y el voto
por correo
se acercan las elecciones presidenciales
y esta será la votación por correo más
grande en la historia de eeuu debido a
la pandemia de kobe 19 la cámara de
representantes aprobó una legislación
con la que busca inyectar 25 mil
millones de dólares al servicio postal y
también bloquea una serie de cambios que
pueden dificultar los comicios presten
atención a lo que dice el presidente
porque todo está diseñado para suprimir
el voto hagan un plan para votar haganlo
para votar temprano para que tengamos un
resultado que sea claro lo más cerca
posible de la noche de elección el
proyecto de ley se enmarca en la
polémica que generó el director del
servicio postal cuando decidió hacer
cambios drásticos como retirar buzones
de recolección y recortar horas extras
con el objetivo de reducir costos aunque
luego dijo que esas medidas no entrarían
en vigencia hasta después de las
elecciones el presidente de donald trump
había instado a rechazar la legislación
presentada por los demócratas
argumentando sin pruebas que este tipo
de votación favorece el fraude
todo esto es una broma de los demócratas
para dar 25 mil millones de dólares
innecesarios para fines políticos sin
hablar de la estafa en el voto por
correo que están tratando de llevar a
cabo en violación de todo lo que nuestro
país representa el proyecto también
tendrá que llegar al senado de mayoría
republicana pero el líder de la cámara
alta- dijo que no la aprobarán si pasa
esta sería una intervención sin
precedentes en la oficina de correos
cuyos fondos provienen del negocio de la
correspondencia y otros servicios y no
del dinero de los impuestos
la clave para controlar la pandemia del
cómic 19 será el desarrollo de una
vacuna exitosa según la oms en france 24
revisamos cómo va el desarrollo de las
posibles inyecciones
de las 169 posibles vacunas contra el
coi 19 que tiene registradas la
organización mundial de la salud 30
están en etapa 2 de ensayos clínicos y 5
se encuentran en la etapa 3 la vacuna
desarrollada por astrazéneca de reino
unido y la universidad de oxford la
vacuna de modernas con países y bayonne
tec de eeuu y la vacuna china de sinovac
y si no fun a partir de la próxima
semana rusia se unirá a este grupo
cuando su vacuna denominada sputnik 5
también comience la tercera y última
etapa de pruebas
muy pocas vacunas son ciento por ciento
efectivas pero incluso si son 50 por
ciento efectivas si podemos reducir a la
mitad del número de infecciones
particularmente infecciones graves que
requieren hospitalización eso ya será un
gran éxito después de los ensayos de
fase 1 y 2 que verifican la seguridad de
una vacuna la fase 3 mide su eficacia en
una población significativa de
voluntarios los podemos estar seguros de
que tendremos una vacuna eficaz
disponible en un futuro próximo no
porque hasta ahora nunca hemos logrado
vacunarnos contra un coronavirus humano
juego de dios' los reguladores
estadounidenses dicen que una vacuna que
proteja al menos al 50 por ciento de las
personas se considerará eficaz eeuu y la
unión europea han comprado por
adelantado cientos de millones de dosis
de posibles vacunas para y se estima que
la suya podría estar lista para
aprobación a partir de octubre mientras
que otras empresas apuntan a finales de
año es una línea de tiempo récord
considerando que las nuevas vacunas
generalmente demoran años en
desarrollarse
y hay preocupación de que el entusiasmo
por crear rápidamente la vacuna contra
el coronavirus pueda llevar a
comprometer la seguridad de la misma
y finalizamos con fútbol pues este
sábado el bayern y el psg ya conocieron
el césped donde jugarán la gran final de
la liga de campeones- que por primera
vez en la historia se celebra sin
público debido a la pandemia y que se
realizó en una sede única en lisboa y
desde allí nuestra enviada especial
natalia ruiz nos amplíe en este informe
ya todo está listo aquí en el estadio da
luz a la casa del benfica y también la
casa por estos días de la liga de
campeones es aquí donde este domingo va
a disputarse la final entre el parís
esta rama y el bayern múnich un estadio
que tiene un aforo de 65.000 personas
pero que este domingo estará vacío ya
que por el coronavirus pues el partido
se jugará sin público sin embargo los
equipos en la tarde de este sábado
hicieron su último entrenamiento lo
hicieron aquí en el estadio primero el
bayern munich y luego en la parís están
llamas sobre el papel el bayern munich
parece ser el gran favorito es el equipo
más eficaz de toda europa con 158 tantos
en esta temporada en la liga de
campeones ha ganado los diez partidos
que ha jugado y sobre todo tiene al
pichichi de la liga de campeones es
decir robert lewandowski que ya lleva
por ahora 15 tantos pero parís también
tiene con quién con qué defenderse y con
quién defenderse ya que tiene a un
kilian pp pero también a neymar júnior y
a ángel di maria ángel di maría a quien
debe tener muy buenos recuerdos en
realidad de este estadio porque es aquí
en 2014
jugaba con el real madrid cuando se
coronó campeón de europa en todo caso
este domingo parece ser una especie de
pelea de disputa entre el david y goliat
david viene a ser éste parís saint
germain que espera tener su primera
corona europea mientras que el bayern
munich espera conseguir su sexta
y mañana con natalia ruiz y con luís
méndez le tenemos preparado un especial
tras la gran final de la liga de
campeones a las 18 10 horas a bogotá
quito lima y ciudad de méjico llegamos
al final de esta emisión no se despegue
de france 24 y cuídese cuídense mucho
del cobi 19
[Música]
france24 punto com